[BEEP]
[THEME MUSIC]
ANDREW: So, OK, so
we're back with Dash.
EMILY: Are we rolling?
ANDREW: We're rolling.
EMILY: Oh.
ANDREW: Now we have to
restart the introduction.
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: I'm sorry.
Hi.
ANDREW: OK, yeah.
We've gone full pirate.
EMILY: [CHUCKLE]
ANDREW: We've gone
full pirate with Dash.
So we're in here, now,
in our Dart interface.
And we would like to have
this be stream-based,
because that is more sort of
idiomatic to Dart and Flutter,
as opposed to just polling it.
EMILY: Getting a single read in.
Yeah.
ANDREW: If it's for C++,
polling something, a value,
would make more sense.
But we have streams
in Dart and Flutter.
And they're great.
So we would like to--
we can keep all this,
that we have, I think.
We just need a new method
for subscribing to a stream.
And then we're going to
have to, in our Java-land,
our Java code, over
here, we're going
to have to find a way
to kick something out.
Rather than just
setting a thing here,
so that we can grab
it when we want it,
we want to actually
kick a value out.
So we'll need a
methodChannel, so that we
can call a method in Dart.
EMILY: So there's actually an
eventChannel class that allows
you to hand a stream-like
object to Dart--
ANDREW: Really?
EMILY: --and then
you can do that.
ANDREW: Is that in the
guide that I probably
didn't read all of?
EMILY: Yeah.
That's part of the-- there's a--
[TYPING]
If you search--
yeah-- eventChannel.
ANDREW: Hold on.
EMILY: Flutter eventChannel.
ANDREW: There is--
Oh, my goodness.
EMILY: Docs.
There we go.
ANDREW: What?
Whoa.
[LAUGHS] That's
the Java end of it.
EMILY: It's all Java!
ANDREW: We're swept
in the Java doc style.
I was like, are we-- did we
just go to another company?
What happened?
EMILY: [CHUCKLE]
ANDREW: What did we just do?
So there's Java involved.
That's-- we know that.
EMILY: Yes.
ANDREW: The Dart-- there we go.
A namedChannel for--
EMILY: Oh, sorry.
I thought you were looking
for the actual Dart version.
ANDREW: No, I was not.
I was looking for this.
I just clicked on
the wrong thing.
Interesting.
I've never had call
to use this yet.
This kind of drives home--
we're talking about how you
won't spend that much time
developing plugins, like this,
because, normally, the Flutter
team is behind a
whole bunch of them.
And the community
makes even more.
This-- my embarrassment kind
of just drives home that point.
EMILY: Well, no, I guess
it just shows that, yeah,
even we're not writing
plugins most of the time.
ANDREW: Yeah, that is true.
Well, tell you what, why
don't we switch seats again?
And you can-- why don't
you show me how it's done?
EMILY: All right.
Cool.
ANDREW: OK.
EMILY: Back on the
laptop of coding.
ANDREW: [CHUCKLE]
EMILY: OK, so let's
start with Dart.
ANDREW: Sure.
EMILY: So we're going to--
wait.
Is this our example?
No.
ANDREW: That's the app.
That's the example app.
EMILY: Oh, OK.
Let's-- where is our Dart?
Here we go.
OK.
So we have a methodChannel.
Let's also declare
a eventChannel.
Static cost eventChannel.
[TYPING]
ANDREW: How long have you
been working with Dart, now,
actually?
[LAUGHTER]
EMILY: I want to say
like, not consecutively,
but a total of five years.
ANDREW: Wow.
OK.
I feel less bad for
not knowing this now,
since I've been working with
Dart for like six months now.
EMILY: All right.
OK, so let's call this--
we'll call it barometer
stream, maybe?
ANDREW: Pressure stream, maybe?
EMILY: Pressure stream.
ANDREW: That will make us--
because we're just so metal.
EMILY: Yeah, it
sounds so hardcore.
ANDREW: Yeah.
EMILY: OK.
And now-- so in our initialize--
I think we also need
to initialize this.
Oh, wait.
ANDREW: Wait, you already
initialized it, right there.
EMILY: Yes.
ANDREW: Right?
Sorry.
OK, so now we need to
have our Dart method that
returns a stream.
So just be static stream.
We want a stream of the--
ANDREW: Yeah, doubles
would be fine.
EMILY: --readings.
And then what do we
want to call this?
ANDREW: This will be a getter.
EMILY: Pressure stream.
ANDREW: Pressure values.
Pressure-- what are you--
pressure stream is fine.
EMILY: OK.
I think, if I can type--
ANDREW: So we have--
OK, so we just-- we're
defining a getter.
So that is a little
teeny function
that will return a
stream of doubles.
And the function, the getter,
itself, is that going to be
asynchronous or is it going to--
EMILY: It's not.
Because-- yeah, sorry.
I was in future mode.
Yeah.
No, the getter is just
returning a stream.
And the stream will
receive updates and make--
ANDREW: But I mean, all
our other methods are
async too, right?
EMILY: Right.
That's why I was
initially-- but then
it says that the results,
if you have async,
the result has to be a future.
And we don't want a
future, because the stream
is going to be getting the--
ANDREW: So we don't want
a future of a stream.
EMILY: Yeah, I guess--
ANDREW: We just want the stream.
EMILY: An Interesting question
is, with this invoking method,
is that asynchronous?
I don't think so.
ANDREW: Well, so the other
calls are asynchronous,
because you have to
pass a message into--
EMILY: And then it has to do--
ANDREW: --the other side.
But we're just going to return--
I assume the eventChannel,
itself, exposes a stream?
EMILY: Yeah, but we're going to
have to pass a message to Java
to say, give me the stream.
ANDREW: OK, but--
EMILY: I think we should be able
to just get away with a stream.
ANDREW: OK, let's start.
And the static analysis will
let us know when we're wrong.
EMILY: Or failing to get a
number, that might work, too.
OK, so then, Channel--
I can type.
ANDREW: Wait,
eventChannel, you mean?
EMILY: Thank you.
You are on top of things here.
ANDREW: I'm paying
attention, because I
don't know what's going on.
EMILY: I think--
do we just return--
no.
There's--
ANDREW: Receive
broadcast stream?
EMILY: Yeah.
Yeah, maybe that.
ANDREW: I'm just looking
for the word "stream."
That's like a--
EMILY: Now, this is going to
read-- oh, this is not VS code.
I'm sorry.
OK, let's see, eventChannel.
ANDREW: This is the downside
to having official support
for so many editors.
EMILY: OK, so stream,
we just returned stream.
So we just return that.
ANDREW: OK, perfect.
EMILY: Great.
ANDREW: And is that a
typed function or are we
going to get stream of dynamic?
EMILY: Oh, right.
So, yes.
And actually-- OK,
here's a thing.
I think we should have
a stream variable,
and only initialize it once.
Because we don't need multiple--
if multiple people-- or if
we subscribe to the stream,
we don't need a
separate Java object.
ANDREW: And it says it's
a broadcast stream, which
can handle multiple listeners.
Right?
EMILY: True.
Yeah.
So let us declare,
make everything static.
This is great.
It's not constant
stream, double.
[TYPING]
No, I was going to
say pressure stream.
Yeah, pressure stream.
OK, and then we'll
say it can return--
oh, I'll just do a click
and return pressure stream
if not null.
And then we're going to
do our call, this thing.
So if-- oh wait, we
need to sign that.
ANDREW: I was--
OK.
[TYPING]
EMILY: Oops.
Question equals no.
Conditions--
ANDREW: Is there are double
question mark equals?
[TYPING]
That is cool.
EMILY: Oh, you didn't
know about that?
Oh, yeah.
That's a newish
feature but, yeah.
Basically it's saying,
if this is null,
do the thing, otherwise,
just have the value.
So now we will return--
ANDREW: Interesting.
EMILY: --pressure stream.
That should work.
OK, so now we've got
all our Dart stuff.
Do we want to delve
into the Java?
ANDREW: So that's-- so on the
Java side, we'll have to make--
so we have methodChannels
on both sides.
So we would need eventChannels
on both sides, too, right?
EMILY: Yes.
ANDREW: All right.
EMILY: So I think
you clicked on--
oh, my gosh.
It's Java.
ANDREW: We all find
our way eventually.
EMILY: So--
ANDREW: Yeah, let's--
EMILY: Do a little bit of that?
you should keep going.
EMILY: OK.
All right.
So in here, we're going to
register our eventChannel.
Thank you.
ANDREW: So we're in the
register with method.
For those of you who
saw us last time,
we talked about
this a little bit.
This is where-- this is called--
when the plug-in
is first spun up.
And so this is the,
hey, get ready.
I'm going to make
some calls on you.
And I want some data from you.
So this is where it
registers that methodChannel,
so it can receive
requests to run methods.
And then--
EMILY: Import it.
And I'm sure there's a shortcut
for this that I am not--
ANDREW: Alt, Enter, yeah.
EMILY: All right,
so there's that.
ANDREW: I'm sure there's
one in VS code, too.
EMILY: Yes, there is.
ANDREW: But I don't know.
I used to use Visual Studio all
the time, and then I stopped.
EMILY: OK, an eventChannel.
ANDREW: What do we have?
EventSink, EndStreamHandler.
EMILY: So here we
have our messenger.
Oh, it's basically
the same stuff.
So registrar.messenger and the
name of the thing that we want.
Yeah, OK.
And then, OK, so then we want
to set this barometer plug-in
as the handler for that.
So I think there
is a set something
handler or stream handler.
EventChannel--
ANDREW: Set stream handler?
EMILY: This one.
It's like it's almost
just exactly what I said.
EventChannel.setStreamHandler,
And it's going to be--
ANDREW: This.
EMILY: --this.
Now-- wait a minute.
So why did we do a new here
instead of-- oh, it's a static.
OK.
Do we want the same object?
No, probably not, a
separate one in case--
what I'm saying is do we want--
ANDREW: Oh, I see
what you're saying.
We're going to want to have--
EMILY: Independent, I think so.
ANDREW: Now I've
caught up with you.
Yeah, so you're going
to want to capture the--
wait.
That's going to give us
two separate instances
of the plug-in.
EMILY: That's what
I was just asking.
ANDREW: Yeah, no.
What I was going to say
is we should capture--
EMILY: If anything,
we should do the same.
ANDREW: --pull that
into a local variable.
EMILY: Great.
ANDREW: And then-- yeah.
No, you had it
right to begin with.
EMILY: OK.
Login.
[TYPING]
ANDREW: Perfect.
And then we're
going to need to--
EMILY: Oh, wait.
ANDREW: Do we need an
interface that we have to--
EMILY: Oh, right.
Yes.
Yeah, so stream handler
expects stream handler.
So we're going to say
implements stream handler.
No?
Oh, yes.
OK.
So now-- all right.
So to implement stream
handler, we must go deeper.
We have on cancel and on listen.
And just like any
other real stream.
ANDREW: Just like any other
stream when somebody wants
to listen, this is where you--
OK.
EMILY: OK.
So let's implement those things.
Now what is it
unhappy about here?
ANDREW: That's the API level
that I still haven't fixed.
EMILY: Oh, OK.
All right, so--
ANDREW: It's the one
line change, that I'm
just really busy, you know?
EMILY: On cancel--
I'm sure there's-- is it Alt,
Enter something for it to be
like--
help me, Andrew.
What is it?
Too late, I'm typing it.
Arguments.
And then why is it not--
ANDREW: For this I think
it's a Ctrl, I, too.
EMILY: Oh.
All right, you
need to access, put
your public, private things.
I'm such a Darter.
ANDREW: Try Ctrl, I
and see if that works.
Boom.
EMILY: Look at that.
Good job, IntelliJ
or Android Studio.
ANDREW: That reminds
me that we're
missing the override
keyword on the others,
but don't worry about it.
[LAUGHS] And the ones
from two weeks ago, but.
EMILY: OK, great.
ANDREW: Clearly optional.
EMILY: So that is--
so now we need to
implement these.
We are going to--
basically, when we
have this stream,
that we have initialized
somewhere-- where did it go?
What is this?
Oh, it's API.
OK.
So we have our eventChannel.
Is this the API?
OK.
So we want to tell
it, when we listen,
that we can start putting
readings into this stream.
ANDREW: So, yeah.
What are the parameters
in on listen.
So that's arguments--
EMILY: Events.
ANDREW: --that we, I guess,
don't really care about.
EMILY: Yeah, because I think
we don't have any arguments,
because we just want the--
so--
ANDREW: And then
that's what we want,
so we get this sink that
we can put stuff in.
EMILY: So I guess we need to--
I think we need to
make an EventSink.
And this is what we are going
to be passing back to Dart.
ANDREW: Do we-- wait,
I thought we got one
in the signature
of the function.
EMILY: Oh, sorry.
Oh, on listen.
Oh, yes.
OK.
ANDREW: Oh, phew.
That's much easier
than making one.
EMILY: OK.
So we are going to--
we have our eventSink.
And we need to read from it?
No.
We need to tell
it that we have--
wait.
OK.
Hold on.
On listen is calling what
or is getting called when?
ANDREW: So that
gets called when?
EMILY: When we are setting
it up, set stream handler.
So we're saying this
plug-in is now listening.
And so now we're saying--
ANDREW: So we need to keep
that, so we can use it, right?
EMILY: Yes.
ANDREW: The eventSink?
EMILY: And so ultimately,
we're going to say something.
ANDREW: That's what
we're going to do, right?
So, OK-- so we have-- our
on listen method means
somebody is listening.
And they give us a
thing to send them data.
So we've got to
put that somewhere.
We need like an mEventSink
EMILY: Yes.
ANDREW: Right?
EMILY: Right.
Yeah, so we're going
to take-- we're-- yeah.
OK.
So we're going to take this
mEventSink, that we've got
and then make one.
So mEventSink, We'll make one.
[TYPING]
ANDREW: There should
be an eventSink class.
That should exist.
There we go.
EMILY: What do I do?
ANDREW: Oh, it's Alt, Enter.
EMILY: Is it functional?
ANDREW: Option, sorry,
because we're on a Mac.
Option and Enter.
[TYPING]
There we go.
EMILY: No.
ANDREW: What just happened?
EMILY: I did Option, Enter.
[TYPING]
ANDREW: OK, that works.
EMILY: All right.
So we have this.
And we want to--
OK, we-- I need to
backup for a second.
ANDREW: Sure.
EMILY: So when-- back in
our Dart code we've got--
do-do-do.
This is our example, this.
So we're saying, I would like
to get the broadcast stream.
Don't we need to-- so, OK--
and then in here
we're going to create
the stream object that we're
passing to Dart, correct?
ANDREW: I thought
we just got one.
EMILY: From on listen.
ANDREW: Oh, sorry.
We're--
EMILY: Right?
ANDREW: I thought you'd switched
back to the other Dart file.
EMILY: Oh, sorry.
I did.
I did briefly.
No, I just want to
talk at a high level,
like the process
of moving things.
So we've got--
ANDREW: We're going
to say-- on Dart,
we're going to say,
give me a stream,
from the registrars, the
plug-in management system.
That's going to go to the
Java class and say, hey,
somebody wants a stream.
And it's going to
call on listen, right?
EMILY: Yes.
And so I guess my question
is, when on listen is called,
we're putting the events from--
where are the events coming in?
That's where I'm unclear.
ANDREW: Oh, sure because
we covered that one
in the other episode.
So that would be in
on sensor change.
EMILY: On sensor change.
So when on listen comes, we're
constructing this eventSink.
And are we just putting this
mLatestReading into eventSink?
ANDREW: I think.
So it's giving us the eventSink.
We would hold it at that
point and then use it.
EMILY: Oh, just-- right.
Add--
ANDREW: And then we
would use it up here
to just dump doubles into.
EMILY: I see.
OK, got it.
ANDREW: I think.
EMILY: So m--
ANDREW: We'll find out.
EMILY: Yes.
So just like this?
[TYPING]
mSink?
ANDREW: Yeah, I think so.
And then, you can
just take that line
and move it up to the
other one, to where
it says mLatestReading.
Yeah, just success
yourself a double.
EMILY: Aha.
ANDREW: Event values.
Oh, or, yeah.
That's even better.
EMILY: Now is there any--
ANDREW: We might want to check--
EMILY: Should we be
adding this typing?
ANDREW: We should probably
check that it's not null there,
because otherwise, if
they haven't listened
yet, we will immediately crash.
EMILY: Oh, event sent.
Yeah, OK.
So if--
ANDREW: Were we smart
enough to do this with Kyle,
then we could just make it a
type safe call or a null safe
call.
EMILY: Not equals a null.
[TYPING]
ANDREW: So if we have
an eventSink, use it.
And then on cancel,
we can just null out--
EMILY: Yeah,
mEventSink equals null.
Gone.
ANDREW: OK, well that's cool.
EMILY: Let's see.
ANDREW: See if it builds,
the old build test.
EMILY: Oh, and yeah.
OK, so we've built. We're
going to see if it compiles.
But then we have to actually,
in our example app, use this.
ANDREW: Actually use
the stream, otherwise
nothing will ever get called.
EMILY: So do have your
Android simulator open?
ANDREW: I do, somewhere.
EMILY: Yes.
There it is.
ANDREW: Hopefully it will
not crash or anything.
OK.
So, yeah let's--
that's a good idea.
Just build it once and
make sure everything--
EMILY: So you're not--
right now we're not going to
see anything from the stream,
because we haven't hooked
it up in our example app.
But we're just making sure that
we don't get horrible runtime
errors.
ANDREW: Incremental changes.
EMILY: Yes, because we
didn't write a test.
So this is our test, right now.
While it's building, let's
jump over to our example.
So what we want to do here--
ooh.
ANDREW: Oh, things happened.
EMILY: Great.
Initialize barometer.
No implementation found
for initialized barometer?
Do we want to--
You've run this on Android?
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
EMILY: Do we want to--
this seems not related to the
code, the changes I was making.
ANDREW: Yeah, let's go look
at the plug-in, real quick,
and just make sure
that nothing got wonky.
So scroll down a little bit.
Initialize barometer
is right there.
EMILY: Initialize barometer,
yeah, that looks good.
ANDREW: That's unusual.
EMILY: This is going well.
I'm going to stash my changes
and then just try and run it.
ANDREW: Just make
sure that it works.
EMILY: Yeah, make
sure it's not me.
ANDREW: That would be great if
we were actually in a git-repo.
[LAUGHTER]
Sometimes I just
make an extra copy
of the project for funsies.
EMILY: Wait, wait,
wait, but why don't you
just even clone another copy?
ANDREW: I know.
EMILY: OK.
OK, well--
ANDREW: That one's on me.
EMILY: Oh, this is
getting exciting.
ANDREW: Wait, why
is it running now?
EMILY: I don't even--
oh no, that's not
what I want to do.
I wanted to clear the console.
Can you clear this console?
ANDREW: Double-click.
EMILY: Is it the cache?
ANDREW: Two-finger
click and you can clear.
EMILY: Clear all, there we go.
I just wanted to--
let's try again.
Maybe we can do a full restart.
No, there's something going on.
Yeah.
And by the way,
here's our pressure.
ANDREW: Yeah, it's
still in the thousands.
So that's there.
EMILY: I feel like there
must be some typo, initialize
barometer.
ANDREW: We could always
close Android Studio
and clean the project and
reopen it, just to be sure.
EMILY: I really wish
this were a git-repo.
Wait, wait, here's
another thought.
What if we check out a
git-repo and do a diff?
ANDREW: That's true.
But I don't know what else--
I mean, we literally ran
this like 45 minutes ago.
EMILY: We didn't-- you
ran the iOS version.
ANDREW: No, I ran
the Android one, too.
EMILY: Oh, OK.
So close this?
ANDREW: Mm-hmm, confirm exit.
EMILY: Confirm.
Terminate.
ANDREW: Terminate.
Then I think you can go into--
if you do--
No, I mean, right
here, in the terminal,
I think you can go do--
EMILY: Oh, just Flutter run?
ANDREW: Just CD
example, I think.
And then do Flutter clean,
which I think is a command.
EMILY: Yes, it is.
ANDREW: And then we can
open Android Studio again.
EMILY: Oh, I could've just
run it from the command.
ANDREW: Oh yeah,
you could do that.
Flutter run-- we have
a -d Android, probably,
because we have it loaded, yeah.
EMILY: Yeah, -d.
Is it--
ANDREW: Android, It
should work, I think.
The dot, I'm thinking?
EMILY: I thought it
was like run from the--
I guess that just--
OK.
ANDREW: Back before I didn't
know that much about Flutter,
and I was working
on an AdMob plug-in,
I had to do it this way.
Because I didn't
know any better.
I had like three editors
open, at all times,
and four simulators trying to
make sure all the little ads
showed up where they
were supposed to.
EMILY: [CHUCKLES]
ANDREW: You're killing me, Dart.
EMILY: OK.
Initialize barometer.
Maybe I accidentally deleted
something when we were editing.
Oh, wait, I closed that.
OK, time to--
[TYPING]
Android Studio.
Do we want to call this?
ANDREW: Yeah, we might have to.
EMILY: They're
yanking us off the--
ANDREW: Yeah, if this were
a "Looney Tunes" cartoon,
the big hook would
be coming for us.
OK.
You want to comment out
the eventChannel stuff,
just see what's--
EMILY: Sure.
ANDREW: We had to
have made a mistake--
I assume-- in there somewhere.
EMILY: I feel like, rather than
that, I suspect I accidentally
deleted something
when I was typing,
somehow selected something.
Because let's see here,
initialize barometer.
Let's remove our eventChannel.
This is so sad.
ANDREW: Somebody's going
to put a comment on this
and tell us that it's
just in another tab.
It's like the barometer pressure
sensor on the simulator.
EMILY: Do I hide--
oh, this thing.
ANDREW: And comment
those, as well.
Is there-- scroll
up a little bit.
EMILY: I feel so unsafe
developing not in a git-repo.
ANDREW: I know.
EMILY: And take this out.
OK.
Yeah?
ANDREW: You can
still go, because we
have this code on GitHub.
And it is possible
to go look at what
it was before today started.
So that's possible.
EMILY: Yeah, that's
what I was saying
is pull down a
separate repo and diff.
ANDREW: Oh, so you
suggested the exact thing,
and then I just repeated your
idea like two minutes later?
EMILY: That's OK.
It's OK.
ANDREW: Takes me
a while sometimes.
EMILY: [CHUCKLES]
You were debugging in your head.
ANDREW: Yeah, I was.
EMILY: OK, so it is something.
ANDREW: Wait, wait.
No.
EMILY: It is something
that I added.
What the heck?
That is--
ANDREW: That is cray-cray.
EMILY: OK, so let us
add back the Java.
ANDREW: Oh, wait.
Those aren't supposed to
have the same name, are they?
EMILY: Oh, my god.
ANDREW: That should
be pressure stream.
That's what it is.
I remember thinking, when you
were in Dart, to look for that.
And I didn't think to look,
here, when we switched over.
But that's overwriting
the string.
So somewhere--
EMILY: It says the type is--
ANDREW: --somewhere in the
registrar, there's a giant map,
I assume, of string to channel.
EMILY: Good catch.
ANDREW: OK.
So we'll uncomment
everything, immediate success.
EMILY: And everything
is going to work.
Yeah.
ANDREW: We'll go bake a cake.
Puppies will appear.
EMILY: Dash will--
ANDREW: Dash will fly
off into the night.
EMILY: Into the low pressure.
OK, wait.
What did we import
here or implement?
ANDREW: Events something?
Stream handler, was that it?
No.
EMILY: Where did this go?
Where did this go?
Barometer plug-in?
Yeah, so this, set
stream handler.
ANDREW: Oh, it must
be stream handler.
[TYPING]
EMILY: I thought it was--
oh, there we go.
OK.
I was going to say, I thought
there was a little more to it.
ANDREW: And then that, I think
that needs to be uncommented.
EMILY: Thank you.
ANDREW: No problem.
As I continue my
rampant backseat coding.
EMILY: Hey, clearly
making mistakes here.
So--
ANDREW: That's OK.
[TYPING]
EMILY: OK.
So now-- phew--
so now, lastly, before the
hook really pulls me off stage,
let's add a little
into our example app.
And then we'll be good.
So this is our mean.
And so we want--
let us-- how about we
just-- is this the state?
ANDREW: Do you want to just
throw a stream builder on it?
EMILY: Yeah.
ANDREW: Just like
below everything
else, just like, and
a stream builder,
or something like that?
EMILY: OK.
Or, I was just going to--
yeah, OK.
Great.
ANDREW: If you had a
better idea, go for it.
Don't let me stop you.
EMILY: No, let's do that.
So we have this column.
This is going to be
beautiful, so we're
going to have raised
and then stream builder.
And then stream is--
what did we call everything?
Is it barometer dot--
where are you even calling this?
ANDREW:
Barometer.pressureStream?
[TYPING]
Is it underscore barometer?
I'm not seeing where
it says defined.
ANDREW: Did it get commented
out in the barometer?
EMILY: Barometer is here.
Where are we calling our--
oh, capital Barometer.
ANDREW: Oh.
EMILY: Woo.
OK, and then--
ANDREW: That one I definitely
should have remembered.
It's not--
EMILY: Oh, my gosh.
ANDREW: It's context and async
snapshot of double, I think.
I only know that, because
I've been doing a lot of stuff
with streams, recently.
EMILY: And this is where
VS code has a little--
you need to say type exactly--
ANDREW: Oh, really?
EMILY: Yeah.
ANDREW: I wonder if there's--
EMILY: This is why I love--
ANDREW: OK, if anybody knows
how to make that just populate.
EMILY: It's probably Command,
I. It's probably like Alt, I.
ANDREW: Yeah.
EMILY: But anyway.
ANDREW: Maybe one of
the commenters that's
still with us can let us know.
Because I often request features
of the IntelliJ plug-in team.
And they're like, yeah,
we already have that.
You just don't know
the keystrokes.
EMILY: Yes, I do--
yes.
I feel like IntelliJ
has a lot of things.
You just need to
know where they are.
ANDREW: Yeah.
EMILY: OK, so now
we are going to--
if snapshot dot--
ooh, that was not--
ANDREW: Is that not what
you were looking for there?
EMILY: Snapshot.hasData.
Let's see-- return text
pressure stream, snapshot.data.
And then we'll say no data,
because, apparently, it's
the 1980s again.
ANDREW: Yeah, sure.
All right.
Is that-- so we probably need
to rebuild the whole thing.
EMILY: Well,
actually-- oh, wait.
Because it-- oh.
ANDREW: See, that's not going
to rebuild the Java, right?
EMILY: Oh, yeah.
Let's just kill all this.
OK.
Back to full
Android Studio mode.
But there's going
to be a type error.
Let's see, what was
it complaining about?
Well, I guess we'll
find out shortly.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
OK, never mind.
No, I was just thinking--
ANDREW: No, there we go.
EMILY: OK, broadcast
stream dynamic is not
subtype of the
type stream double.
So I think we need to do a
little typing, because I--
pressure stream--
ANDREW: Oh, wait.
Where's the method where
you get the as broadcast
or receive broadcast stream?
EMILY: On Java?
ANDREW: Yeah.
EMILY: That's why I was
asking if we need to--
ANDREW: Oh no, in the
Dart, in barometer.dart.
I remember wondering if I--
EMILY: Oh.
ANDREW: So there's add--
can you Command click
on receive broadcast stream?
Does that have a
type parameter on it?
EMILY: Should be dynamic.
ANDREW: No, it does not.
OK.
EMILY: So do we need to
do a cast like dot as?
ANDREW: Do a dot map?
EMILY: Or dot map, probably.
ANDREW: Yeah, map would be
the thing to do I think.
EMILY: OK, so goodbye
little fancy thing here.
If pressure stream equals null.
[TYPING]
So, well, I guess we can do this
all on one line, but whatever.
So we take-- we're going to map
our value and map to double.
ANDREW: Yeah, I
think that's the--
EMILY: values
ANDREW: --that's the bidness.
EMILY: Right.
And then we'll just assign
that to pressure stream.
[TYPING]
OK.
[GASP]
And now we can use this.
Let's see, moment of truth here.
ANDREW: Oh, my god.
Flutter victory.
[LAUGHTER]
We rule air pressure.
EMILY: You are now
ready to use this app
to help you measure
your air pressure.
ANDREW: Yeah, we're ready
for the hot air balloon now.
EMILY: Fly high.
ANDREW: Yeah.
Awesome, OK.
EMILY: Do we declare
victory while we're ahead?
ANDREW: So let's-- yeah, we
definitely need to declare
victory and get out of here.
Let's talk about
everything we just did.
EMILY: Oh, yes.
ANDREW: So we came in and--
EMILY: We added--
ANDREW: --there was a desk.
And we sat down.
EMILY: We added an iOS app
using good old Objective-C.
Then we attempted to
publish the package.
And we ran into
an error, which we
are going to look into
and get back with you.
Or someone is going to be
like, you forgot a semicolon.
ANDREW: Yeah, someone
will tell us where.
EMILY: And then we
streamified the Java version.
I think that the last
step-- well, there's
two last steps-- would be to
streamify the iOS version.
ANDREW: So we still need
to do that, which we might.
We might just go on
in a couple of weeks.
But we should.
Hopefully, one or both
of us will have time
to finish this up and get it up
on GitHub in a finished state.
Maybe Dash can do that.
EMILY: Yes, she's good
at getting code done.
And then just, yeah,
a little cleanup,
maybe actually adding a test.
ANDREW: Yeah, we talked
about methodChannels
versus eventChannels,
which I learned about,
having not known about them.
Cool.
All right.
I think that's about it.
EMILY: If you're still here,
you should win a prize.
ANDREW: There you go.
All right, guys.
We'll see you in
a couple of weeks.
Hope you enjoyed it.
EMILY: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]